PROFESSOR: If you tell
someone solve this equation
for l equals zero--
so you have this
effective potential
for the real equation--
solve it for l equals zero
and you find some energies.
You solve it for l equals 1,
and you've found some energies.
You solve it now
for l equals two
and you found some energies.
Well, we found
them all together,
but something
extraordinary happened
there was no a priori
reason the system should
have been so simple.
It might have happened that
these states would have not
been aligned with
the previous states.
Nothing we've explained
in this course
predicts that this
would have happened,
this perfect alignment with
extreme amount of degeneracy.
Because you have an l
equals 2 multiplet here.
That means five states.
So there is
degeneracy, but that's
implicit in angular momentum.
It has an explanation.
But why would there
be a degeneracy
between l equals 1 solutions
and l equals 2 solutions?
Total mystery, actually.
And this led to all kinds
of interesting discoveries
that have to do with the
Runge-Lenz vector, which
is some conserved vector
in planetary orbits.
In planetary orbits,
in Newton's theory,
an elliptical orbit is
the general solution.
Nevertheless, elliptical
orbits do not precess.
So you have an ellipse,
it goes like that.
It's not going around
and rotating the ellipse
at the same time.
The precession of an ellipse is
not allowed by Newton's theory.
It's allowed by
Einstein's gravity theory,
and in fact, the precession
of mercury was measured.
But there is no precession
in Newton's theory,
and there's no precession
in a hydrogen atom,
in a sense, as you will see.
And that explains, actually
in a rather interesting way--
but I'm not saying how yet--
why there is this
extra degeneracy.
In fact, if you had
solved the problem
of an infinite spherical, well,
you will solve that in 805.
Infinite spherical well.
Suppose there's infinite square
well-- infinite spherical well.
Inside a sphere of radius
A, the potential is 0.
Outside the sphere of radius
A, the potential is infinite.
That potential that
looks so symmetric--
the l equals 0
states are like this.
The l equal 1 states
are like that.
The l equal 2 states
are like that,
and there's never
any coincidence.
So this coincidence
between the l
equals 0, l equals 2, l
equals 2 is very special.
It just doesn't happen often.
It's a sign of an
extra symmetry.
This could only be explained
because the hydrogen
atom has an extra symmetry
you're not aware of.
So that's why this
Runge-Lenz vector
has to do with
that extra symmetry
and explains this effect.
And we'll get some
intuition about it today.
A few more remarks
to get your intuition
working on the hydrogen atoms.
Z equals 1, we write
the wave function.
This is the most
famous wave function.
Pi a0 cubed e to
the minus r over a0.
And this is for z equals 1.
n equals 1, l equals
0, m equals zero--
the complete ground state.
It's interesting to note and
try to think, OK, suppose they
gave you the z equals 1 answer.
How do you get z
different from 1?
Can I just do something
with this solution?
Well, somehow it's written
here, but I don't give here
the normalization because
it's impossibly complicated
to write the general form
for the normalization.
So how should I
think of changing
if somebody would
have told me this
is the answer for Z equals 1?
How do I get to Z
different from 1?
And then I think
of the potential,
and the potential
was e squared over r.
That was the potential
before, V of r.
And it will pass
to a V of r that
has minus Ze squared over r.
Because now you have a nucleus
with Z protons interacting
with one electron, so
that's how it changed.
So naturally, what seems
to be the change here,
and you could imagine just
solving it without the Z
and then adding the Z, is that
everywhere that you have e
squared you should
put Z times e squared.
And then you think of a0.
a0 was h squared
over me squared.
We calculated that
some time ago.
And then if e squared
goes to Ze squared,
this will go to 1 over Z
squared over me squared.
So it will go to a0 over Z.
So you change a0 to a0 over Z.
And these are the two changes.
One is implicit on the
other, but many times you
write the formula
in a mixed way.
Look at that energy.
If you would have looked
at this without the Z
and you would have
said, oh, e squared
is replaced by Ze squared,
you would have put a single Z.
But there is a Z squared here,
and it comes because 1z is here
and the other z is in
the a0 because a0 also
has the e squared.
So you have to be aware
that we write these things.
And this is intuitively a very
nice way to write the energy,
because it has the right units--
electric charge squared
divided by distance.
But you could have
written everything
with h bar, something
like that, in which case
the z squared might have
been less surprising.
We see here, however, the z is
appearing in the right place
because of the a0.
So here, I was right.
e to the minus zr over a0.
And can I get the
normalization even right?
At this moment, yes.
Let's do the same change here.
Pi a0 cubed, z cubed.
And this must be right,
because, in fact,
if this wave function
was normalizable--
not normalizable;
was normalized--
when you do the integral,
somehow the a0 did not matter,
must not matter.
You checked psi squared
integrated over volume
is equal to 1.
The a0 must be canceling here.
And therefore, if it works for
a0, it must work for a0 over z,
and that must be
a wave function.
So that's fine.
That's one thing you could ask.
Another thing that you could
ask is, at least intuitively,
why did we get this factor here?
Why did we get this exponential?
And that's also not
mysterious at all.
This comes from the
differential equation.
It comes up rather immediately
from the differential equation.
You have minus h squared over
2m d second u dr squared,
plus some sort of number--
you don't care how
much-- u over r squared
in the effective potential,
minus some number over r
times u is equal to Eu.
This was your radial
differential equation.
And this r goes to infinity.
As r goes to infinity,
you get minus h
squared over 2m d second u
dr squared is equal to Eu,
roughly.
That's the key terms.
And from here, d
second u dr squared
is equal to minus 2
mE over h squared u.
And that gives you
an exponential,
and the exponential must be
of the right value, which
we can calculate easily from
the expression for the energy.
So the expression for
the energy gives you
em equals minus z squared
over 2a0 e squared, times 1
over n squared.
And I can change this
thing into minus z squared.
Recall what's the value of
the fine structure constant.
I can replace e squared from
a0 to get the following thing
over 2a0 times h
squared over ma0.
That is 1 over m squared.
A little bit of manipulation.
So at the end, minus
2mEn over h squared,
which is what I need from
the differential equation.
I must multiply by
minus 2m over h squared.
You see that minus the 2m over
h squared, they will disappear.
So you get here z squared
over n squared a0 squared.
A little bit of manipulation.
So what are we trying to get?
We want to understand
immediately
where this came from.
And we see it.
It comes from the asymptotic
form of the differential
equation for a solution.
So I calculate the value of
the right-hand side is this,
and therefore this
differential equation
now looks like the du dr
squared equals z squared over n
squared a0 squared u.
Are indeed, from
here, the solutions
are exponentials
of the square root
of this, which is z over na0r.
And that's a quicker derivation
of a feature of the wave
function.
It's almost like you want to
look at this wave function,
and you want to
say, I understand
where everything comes from.
And I don't have to solve
pages and pages of differential
equations to see why I need
this, why I need that much.
I know I need this
from r equals zero.
I know this degree.
I need it from the node theorem.
Everything sort of has a
reason for being there,
and we should understand.